a 50-year marriage
um but is it realistic to expect you're
going to be happy all 50 years no but
now it's not expected that you stay in
an unhappy relationship Generations
before yes because there are many
reasons not just because well I think
Generations before would laugh at us to
be honest I think the wives from the
1950s would laugh at us when we leave
because we're not happy because you know
she's like I had a whole side chick
across town he had a whole second family
and you guys are leaving because you're
not happy
do you all come from Happy homes with
parents that stay together I mean not um
yeah I mean I did like I have two
parents they have ten kids and
um I mean they weren't always happy
though and so what I would see is like
growing up my friend's parents would be
unhappy and they decided to get divorced
and it didn't it wasn't really great for
the kids where my parents there were
times when they were unhappy and they
just figured it out
and just you know they because because
to them it was always about us it wasn't
about their happiness it was about us I
can attest to that um my uh my
grandmother
um her my grandfather had a family
across town she stayed with him I always
asked like well why didn't you leave and
she's like I just stayed with them I had
kids with them that was my husband and
he had the other family and it wasn't
like she didn't know about them or
anything she just stayed and that's
something that's very taboo nowadays to
stay with someone that has a family
across town I think it's just
easier for us to be like I don't like it
I don't want it I'm gonna choose
something else I think we've become
quite individualistic as a culture so we
don't maybe think about the community or
the bigger picture or like like raising
the Next Generation so you you put
yourself first and your own like
happiness first yes so I think the they
were
more realistic in terms of what they
could achieve in the sense of
in those times if you had three kids by
a man you know that the grass isn't
green on the other side
that you might have been a brand new
Mercedes but having three kids is like
being a cat D written off vehicle like
people how many managers how many men
are really going to take you on in in in
that case and that's just being the
reality of it and that's me like
obviously I hate to bring anecdotes in
it that's me growing up around
loads of dysfunctional relationships
like
he really wants to take you on like that
you just your caliber man that's gonna
date you it's not what and it was like
when when you were 23
yeah and also they didn't I don't know
when child support started or when all
of the government handouts started but
if like back in the day that wasn't
really a thing it's like you stay with
the man because he's a provider of the
family if I leave that means I have to
take care of the X amount of kids that I
have at home I have to get a job take
care of them have to find out who's
going to babysit them take them to
wherever it's like I'd rather stay with
a man that's providing for the family
and deal with whatever stuff that he has
going on because
it's gonna be harder on me to leave than
to stay but nowadays it's easy for women
to be like okay peace out I signed a
prune up or I get half the stuff that he
has or I get money for him from Child
Support so it's like okay either way
it's easy for me to leave than to stay
because there is consequences and when
you take away the consequences of in
society like people people damn near do
whatever they want you know because
before you might be homeless if you if
you left your husband I know but it just
like everything you're saying is like
you have to put up with what he's doing
or else you're going to be worse off now
it's like well if he's being a [ __ ] you
can still leave well but that's that's
through the mindset maybe like men
you've dealt with in the past have it
like haven't been great I don't because
that's I don't know you personally but
that's that's what an example like your
example my personal like my family so um
my mom and dad met when they were 17.
Love at First sights
40 years together
happy families he left I was in my 20s
all right so he decided after a year A
bad year of marriage he met someone else
and he decided to leave he came from a
family that was very you said this was
your dad yeah okay so I was in my 20s so
it's not like I had this like childhood
where I was hating men like you know
um but he came from a family
his parents were together very religious
he had
for brothers and a sister
um none of them none of their marriages
worked
either through one of them cheating one
of them leaving they were unhappy I just
I don't think it's enough to say that a
woman needs to be a certain way in order
for a marriage to work because it's not
true
did you ever ask your like dad for his
side of the story oh yeah no yeah like I
was the one that found out about the
affair like I confronted him the night
before he left and oh my gosh yeah I
would be I would be so sad it was awful
yeah I couldn't even imagine but at the
same time they had a bad year and he was
horrendous I was living with him at the
time he was horrendous to be around and
I wanted him to be happy so I was like
go be free but
now I think that was a terrible way to
deal with a 40-year marriage or
relationship they were together 40 40
years and he ended it in an email he
went away to Afghanistan and sent her an
email to me and my two brothers he sent
an email all he did was change the name
from like each of our names basically
the woman that moved from country to
Country to Country she was with him
through the war like
yeah multiple Wars sacrificed her life
like everything she wanted to do for him
and he still left
like it was horrendous is that what he
said he said it was one bad year it was
18 months that he so he was in
Afghanistan work stopped funds were
withdrawn and he came back to England he
hated living in England he was unhappy
she was unhappy because he was unhappy
they didn't talk they were at each
other's throats they didn't communicate
he then sought solace in another woman
that he knew in school they reconnected
on Facebook
like social media's out here ruining
lives
so it's
it's not enough to say that and and this
is just an example there are many
examples of women being good we're good
women and it's still ending so so I
don't disagree with you that like like I
think that's horrible like yeah that
that I'm sorry that happened to you
actually that's that would be that would
traumatize me but the majority of the
time women are the ones leaving
and the divorce rate increased after
hormonal hormonal birth control was
introduced
so and I the reason I think women leave
more is because we're incentivized to do
so to the point we're paid
so because we can we can leave and take
half half have you ever heard the phrase
it's cheaper to keep her
yeah excuse me
so so we don't have a consequence for
leaving which we had before because we
can take half his money like like most
of the richest women on earth
um got their money through divorce
because if a man leaves with the kids
the woman doesn't have to pay child
support the woman doesn't have to
contribute anyways she can go out and
live her life yeah and the man because
the man is a provider he still has to
work and do everything but do you all
come from places where the man is the
provider and the woman is just like this
freeloader no no I think that's that's
quite divisive to say freelo though
because she's got different roles yeah
but she's got a different role